สวัสดีและยินดีต้อนรับกลับสู่ซีรีส์คอร์ส Variational Quantum Eigensolver
ฉันชื่อ Victoria Lipinska และในวิดีโอนี้เราจะมาดูกันว่าจะแทนปัญหา VQE
ในแบบที่คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเข้าใจได้อย่างไร
โดยทั่วไปแล้ว ปัญหาเคมีควอนตัมจะแสดงในรูปของพลังงาน
ของระบบ
เราเรียกตัวดำเนินการที่อธิบายพลังงานเหล่านี้ว่า Hamiltonian
ขั้นแรก เราต้องทำการ quantize มัน
นั่นคือแสดงมันในภาษาของเคมีควอนตัม
ซึ่งเรียกอย่างเป็นทางการว่า second quantization
ถ้า Hamiltonian อธิบายปฏิสัมพันธ์ของ fermion เช่น
พลังงานของอิเล็กตรอนใน spin orbital เราจะเรียกสิ่งนี้
ว่า fermionic Hamiltonian และนี่คือจุดเริ่มต้นของเราในวันนี้
แต่ qubit มีภาษาของตัวเอง
ตัวดำเนินการในโลกของ qubit อธิบายด้วย Pauli operators
ดังนั้นสิ่งที่เราโฟกัสตอนนี้คือการแสดง fermionic operators
ในรูปของ qubit operators
มีความสอดคล้องแบบหนึ่งต่อหนึ่งที่เรียบง่าย
ระหว่างสถานะ zero และ one สำหรับ fermion และ qubit
ดังนั้นการ map ระหว่างสถานะก็ตรงไปตรงมาเช่นกัน
แต่การ map ของตัวดำเนินการนั้นซับซ้อนกว่านิดหน่อย
fermionic Hamiltonian แสดงด้วย creation และ
annihilation operators
งานของเราคือทำให้คอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเข้าใจ
Hamiltonian ได้ง่ายขึ้น
เราจะใช้เครื่องมือทางคณิตศาสตร์ในการ map fermionic Hamiltonian
ไปเป็น qubit Hamiltonian ด้วย gate
พูดง่ายๆ คือเราจะแปลภาษา
จากภาษาเคมีควอนตัมไปเป็นภาษาการคำนวณควอนตัม
ลองนึกภาพสองสายโซ่ อันหนึ่งมี fermion
นั่นคือภาษาเคมีควอนตัม
และอีกอันมี qubit นั่นคือภาษาการคำนวณควอนตัม
มองเผินๆ การ map ดูตรงไปตรงมาใช่มั้ย?
ทั้งสองกรณีเราเห็นระบบที่มีสองระดับ
สำหรับ fermion เราจะมี fermion หนึ่งตัวในสถานะนั้น
หรือไม่มี fermion เลย
และสำหรับ qubit เราจะมีสถานะ 0 หรือสถานะ 1
แต่จริงๆ แล้วมันซับซ้อนกว่านั้น
ความแตกต่างระหว่างสายโซ่ของ qubit กับสายโซ่ของ fermion
เป็นเรื่องพื้นฐานมากในฟิสิกส์ ที่เรียกว่า exchange symmetry
fermion สองตัวไม่สามารถอยู่ในสถานะเดียวกันได้
แต่สำหรับสายโซ่ของ qubit นั้นต่างออกไปโดยสิ้นเชิง
qubit สองตัวสามารถอยู่ในสถานะเดียวกันได้
เพราะ qubit ไม่ใช่ fermion
ดังนั้นเราต้องหาวิธีแปลระหว่างสองสายโซ่นี้
ในปี 1928 นักวิจัยสองคนคือ Jordan และ Wigner
แสดงให้เห็นว่า fermionic operators ของทั้งสายโซ่
สามารถแทนได้อย่างแม่นยำในรูปของ qubit operators
นี่คือการ map ที่ตรงไปตรงมาที่สุดสำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
ตัวอย่างเช่น สามารถใช้มัน map การครอบครอง
ของ orbital ไปยัง spin ของ qubit หนึ่งตัว
ในทางปฏิบัติ การ map นี้สำหรับ Hamiltonian จะได้ผลลัพธ์เป็นผลรวมแบบถ่วงน้ำหนักของ Pauli operators
นี่เป็นข้อเท็จจริงที่สำคัญมาก ซึ่งอยากให้จำไว้
และเราจะกลับมาพูดถึงเรื่องนี้ในโมดูลถัดไปที่เราจะพูดถึง
วิธีที่ variational circuit ถูก execute บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
การ map ข้างต้นหมายความว่าถ้าเรามี เช่น
fermionic operators 14 ตัว เราจะ map ปัญหาไปยัง 14 qubit
โชคดีที่มีวิธีฉลาดๆ ในการลดจำนวน qubit
และใช้ทรัพยากรควอนตัมน้อยลงเพื่อให้ได้ประสิทธิภาพที่ดีกว่าจากคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
โดยทั่วไปในระบบโมเลกุล เราจะรู้
symmetry ทางฟิสิกส์บางอย่างของ Hamiltonian
เช่น จำนวนอิเล็กตรอนทั้งหมดคงที่
ข้อมูลนี้สามารถใช้ลดขนาดของปัญหาได้
โดยไม่สูญเสียข้อมูลที่เกี่ยวข้อง
เราเรียกเทคนิคนี้ว่า active space reduction
ซึ่งช่วยลดจำนวนทรัพยากร กล่าวคือ จำนวน qubit
ก่อนการ map qubit แบบ Jordan-Wigner transformation
ขั้นตอนนี้คำนวณ Hamiltonian ที่มีประสิทธิภาพ
และทำให้เราใช้ qubit น้อยลงเป็นผลลัพธ์
สำหรับตัวอย่างที่มี 14 orbital ของเรา
เทคนิคนี้ลดจำนวน qubit เหลือแค่หก
ตอนนี้เราสามารถไปได้ไกลกว่านี้อีกกับการลดขนาด
เราสามารถใช้การ map แบบต่างๆ
ซึ่งซับซ้อนกว่า Jordan-Wigner นิดหน่อย
ตัวอย่างที่พบบ่อยที่สุดคือ parity mapping
Parity mapping ไม่ได้ map การครอบครองของ orbital ลงบน qubit
แต่ map parity ของ orbital ลงบน qubit แต่ละตัวแทน
เราจะไม่ลงรายละเอียดทางคณิตศาสตร์ที่นี่
แต่สิ่งสำคัญที่ต้องรู้คือการ map นี้มี redundancy เพิ่มเติม
ซึ่งสามารถนำมาใช้ตัด qubit ออกได้อีกสองตัว
ดังนั้นในตัวอย่าง 14 orbital ของเรา จึงลดจาก 14 qubit
เป็น 6 qubit ด้วย active space reduction แล้วเหลือ 4 qubit
ด้วยการลด qubit สองตัวใน parity mapping
มาพูดถึง transformation อีกแบบหนึ่งสั้นๆ กัน
อีก mapping ที่ใช้กันทั่วไประหว่าง fermionic
และการแทนด้วย qubit คือ Bravyi-Kitaev transformation
Bravyi-Kitaev transformation ใช้ qubit ในการ encode ข้อมูล
เกี่ยวกับทั้ง occupation number และ parity ของ quantum state
Bravyi-Kitaev transformation รวม occupation number และข้อมูล parity
สำหรับ molecular orbital basis ขนาด N
จะใช้ qubit จำนวน N เช่นกัน
แต่ข้อมูลที่เก็บอยู่ใน qubit แต่ละตัว
จะแตกต่างกันขึ้นอยู่กับว่าเป็น qubit ตัวไหน
นั่นคือเมื่อ index ของ qubit เป็นเลขคู่
มันจะเก็บ occupation number ของ
orbital number ที่ตรงกันเหมือนใน Jordan-Wigner mapping
เมื่อ index ของ qubit เป็นเลขคี่ qubit จะเก็บ parity ของ
ชุด occupation number หนึ่งๆ Bravyi-Kitaev transformation มีประสิทธิภาพสูงสุด
เมื่อจำนวน qubit เข้าใกล้ power of two
Bravyi-Kitaev mapping รวมข้อดีจากทั้ง Jordan-Wigner
และ parity transformation
มันลดจำนวน qubit ที่แต่ละ Hamiltonian term กระทำต่อ
สิ่งนี้สำคัญสำหรับการจำลองควอนตัม เพราะ term ที่
กระทำต่อ qubit จำนวนมากใน Hamiltonian
ต้องการ circuit ที่ยาวกว่าในการจำลอง
ซึ่งหมายความว่า circuit depth
จะลดลงด้วย Bravyi-Kitaev transformation และโดยทั่วไป
เราจะได้ผลลัพธ์ที่ดีกว่าบน hardware
นี่คือการปรับปรุงจาก Jordan-Wigner transformation
ซึ่งให้ Hamiltonian ที่มี qubit ในระดับ order of N
สรุปแล้ว ในวิดีโอนี้เราสำรวจวิธีการ map
fermionic Hamiltonian ไปยัง qubit Hamiltonian
ในตอนถัดไปเราจะมาดูกันว่าจะเลือก state ที่ดีที่สุดได้อย่างไร
รวมถึง variational form หรือ circuit
แล้วเจอกัน